for many of us saying goodbye to 2021
was something to celebrate but in terms
of your bank balance 2022 has some
unwelcome surprises in store
terms like inflation interest rates and
wholesale energy prices might all sound
a bit like things that someone else
needs to worry about but they could all
be about to make our lives that bit more
expensive so here's everything you need
to know about your bills this year
[Music]
you might have already noticed the price
of your shopping has gone up the cost of
food is linked to labor shortages and
other problems across the supply chain
partly thanks to the pandemic and partly
thanks to brexit their problems which
aren't going away anytime soon so it's
more important than ever to be able to
you know shop around and make sure that
you're shopping with the right
supermarket because they all tend to
offer loyalty points um which will give
you money off of your purchases but
they're not all created equal
official figures which include other
costs faced by households paint a
similar picture for example in november
petrol rose by over 5 in just a month
and if you want to buy a used car well
that will cost you over 31 more than it
would have done last year
all those price rises are driving up the
overall rate of inflation it was up 5.1
percent in the year to november that
might not sound like a lot but it's the
highest it's been in a decade and way
above the two percent officials aim to
keep it up and there's likely more bad
news to come on that the bank of england
forecasts inflation will soon surge to
six percent
to try and slow it down the bank of
england has one key tool up its sleeve
raising interest rates before christmas
it announced interest rates were going
up from 0.1 percent to 0.25
so what it means is for really high
interest debt it gets more and more
expensive because you owe not just the
amount you owe but you're also having to
pay every month to service that debt and
that debt depends on the interest rate
that's set so potentially bad news for
your bills in the short term especially
if you have a mortgage or other
borrowings but it could lead to better
news in the future in theory those extra
costs leads to less disposable income
being spent the economy slowing and
inflation decreasing in other words a
halt to those rising prices all well and
good but there's another very
significant cost rise on the way
with winter in full swing households
around the uk are using more energy to
keep us warm that plus a combination of
global forces means that the wholesale
cost of gas is soaring and sadly it's
only a matter of time before that cost
will be passed on to the consumer
in april the energy price cap which
limits the amount consumers pay will be
adjusted by the regulator ofgem as a
result energy bills will probably rise
by more than 50 percent to 2000 pounds a
year for the average family household
what's happened is you've seen the
wholesale price of energy go up which
has meant that smaller suppliers have
actually gone bust some of them so
because there are less supplies in the
market it means that again prices are
going up and they are going up quite
substantially so you know it is a really
really critical time here's what else is
on the horizon national insurance tax is
going up by 1.25
in april but workers on the basic
minimum wage will receive a boost that
month too as it's set to go up to 9.50
an hour and while train fares are
expected to rise by 3.8 in march
anyone retiring on the full new state
pension will see their earnings rise by
290 pounds this year there are some
reasons to be cheerful but there's also
a lot for families to grapple with the
year is likely to be tough for many